anime uproar what up anime fans as many
of you know we've been doing weekly
reviews of Dragon Ball super episodes
and between those weekly reviews we have
been doing some special dragon ball
super related videos including top ten
coolest super characters be sure to
check that out if you haven't already so
I wasn't really gonna do top times
strong as Super characters because their
lists out there already
but there was interest for it so I
thought [ __ ] it let's do it we'll give
you guys our thoughts on the top 10
strongest super characters let's jam
number 10 would be golden Frieza he's
definitely very powerful in fact he
could have the potential to be more
powerful than Goku and Vegeta with a lot
less work and Goku even says he is more
powerful it's just he has a master his
golden form when they fight and that's
why his stamina is weak and he can't
keep up eventually if he did more
training he probably could have
surpassed Vegeta and Goku with relative
ease and practically no time at all but
he was too hot-headed so he'll remain at
number 10 number 9 would be Vegeta but
Jia and Goku have been toe-to-toe for a
lot of these series which is what I
enjoy after Goku achieved Super Saiyan
God form sort of aji de and then they
both trained with Wiese and they were
head-to-head but then goku as you guys
all know with his transformation and
then Kaioken on top of that was way too
much for Regina to keep up so Vegeta is
going to stay at nine while number eight
would go to Goku Goku with his Kaioken
technique is almost almost as strong as
beetles or if he's not he definitely has
the potential to be it is cool how in
this series they actually showed the
negative side effects of Kaioken right
before he could just take a sense of
being but now there seems to be like a
lot more consequences and a lot harder
to deal with circumstances as we've seen
in the episode 43 where it's gonna take
a little bit to get his key
back to normal and pretty much King Kai
said hey man don't use this if you keep
using it
your Chi might stay messed up forever so
although Goku has surpassed Vegeta in
strength
well it's yet to see if they'll be able
to actually keep on using Kaioken or not
number seven would goes to hit hits has
even crazier potential to grow stronger
in Lima in less time than golden Frieza
he for example has no trouble beating
Goku and the only reason he hasn't grown
with his times capability and so long
was because no one challenged him but it
seems as soon as someone challenges him
he grows rapidly so I mean he hasn't yet
surpass Champa and Vado's
but it seems like he could that's what I
was really looking forward to Champa and
hit fighting one another before the Omni
King showed up but whatever maybe we'll
get a chance later on I feel like the
stronger hits opponent the stronger
he'll become but for now he stays at
number seven next
number six has to go - Champa Champa is
a god of destruction like beerus for
universe 6
but unlike beetles he's out of shape
both Wiese and vados remark that Champa
would lose in a fight against abuse just
cuz he is out of shape it's as simple as
that number 5 goes to beerus he as we've
seen Toriyama explained he is weaker
than Wiese and by extension vadas for
quite a bit weaker as well if if Coke
was six
Bureaus was a 10 that we would be a 15
so even though he's definitely stronger
than golden Frieza than Shenron even
that majeeda and then Goku and hit and
even Champa he just can't match up with
his sensei wheeze that brings us to
number 4 wheeze has proven to be
stronger than all the characters below
him on this list he doesn't sweat the
small stuff he doesn't even sweat the
Omni King showing up he seems very
capable of his abilities unlike beetles
sometimes what's more he can turn back
time which is definitely very helpful if
he ever actually
got into a life and that's struggle so
yeah screw time skips time travels where
it's at now at this point most of it
becomes speculation because we've seen
the reaction to a lot of these
characters that would have been
introduced recently like the Omni King
but we don't know for certain their
strengths so at this point we're pretty
much talking about speculation and
guessing which although educated at the
end of the day might turn out to be
wrong so let's see number three vados so
I believe that wheezes sister does seem
to be stronger than them she usually
gets the upper hand in their verbal back
and forth and she's the only one that
I've ever seen get a reaction out of
Wiese pretty much vados is the older
sister and that's probably why she is
more powerful next is probably gonna be
the Omni Kings bodyguards who we saw
towering over him so pretty much who I'm
guessing here I mean if this guy has
bodyguards but we haven't we're not
don't know for certain that they're
bodyguards they may be also sensei's so
potentially they could be even stronger
than the Omni King which we don't know
right it could be a wheeze and beerus
kind of situation which is very possible
but for now i believe according to
beerus is reaction it seems that the
Omni King is more powerful but like a
guy that powerful has his bodyguards
damn right they're gonna be powerful so
pretty much it's likely that it even
takes the time to have bodyguards there
at least stronger than be tellson Champa
and probably stronger than we sand
battles or else they'd be useless and
then number one on the king like I said
this can switch around if on the King's
bodyguards
our sensei's but it doesn't seem like
that since this guy's the king of
everything and beerus and champa
definitely believe he's the strongest in
the universe who even at blink of an eye
can destroy entire universes sidenote
and super Shenron is also probably up
there with the Omni King I mean he can
easily destroy universes in the blink of
an eye just like army king and beetles
accounts for that he
pretty much do anything but he doesn't
really count in this list because he
doesn't have his own freewill
right he's just a slave to others
because he's more like a tool than an
actual free-willed entity there you have
it
not a long video but just getting to the
point and let you guys know our top 10
strongest dragon ball super characters
and the rationale behind that of course
this may all change as we get more
information but that's the fun of
speculation like we can guess we can
play Sherlock and we can see if we end
up being right we're definitely gonna
have stronger characters introduced soon
and the characters we know are gonna get
stronger and I can't wait for example
for Future Trunks to show up and see how
how strong he is how much he boosts the
others and to see who this mysterious
villain black Goku from the future is
gonna be and how this guy's would be so
powerful that even the Omni King can't
stop so we're definitely gonna have to
revise this list before you know it
but for now especially while we're in
the filler episodes it doesn't hurt to
speculate and it can be a hell of a lot
of fun so let me know what you guys
think let me know your theories in the
comment section below and if you enjoy
this video like and subscribe and we'll
see you for the next episode review
until next time see you space cowboys